soyez les bienvenus en festival fait
quatre saisons
[Musique]
regardez farinas mais c'est quoi cette
coiffure elle a volé la poussière de fée
bleue et sans poussière on ne peut pas
voler il faut qu'on la récupère des
pirates c'est peut-être des gentils
pirates bah voyons
pour la capitaine
à lamballe ça explique la coiffure cette
poussière appartient à la vallée des
fées
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'elle a fait elle a échangé
nos talents te voilà bricoleuse repenser
chose immédiatement
[Musique]
voulez-vous bras droit pied gauche à tes
ordres
le pouvoir de la poussière de fée nous
appartient nous allons nous
j'ai cassé quelque chose
apparemment je suis une fée des animaux